hello everyone i'm coming at you here
from the beautiful woods of western
sweden uh because i have an announcement
to make so have any of you ever asked
yourself where does the music in all
these let's talk religion videos come
from i've seen a lot of you ask that
question in the comments and i know that
some of you already know because i've
answered that question
before
the fact is that most of the music in my
videos were made by me so over the years
i've composed
various
musics and
tracks for these different videos both
as background music and for the
different intros to the different series
and so on now i have released some of
that music before for example in an ep
called desert wanderings which came out
about two years ago but today i'm
actually releasing a full album of
tracks so nine tracks of music that i
made for the videos on this channel
mostly background music that you've
heard in all these different videos i'm
sure you'll recognize a lot of these
songs
the album is called climbing
and the album art looks like this and so
you can find this album right now on all
the streaming platforms it's on spotify
it's on apple music and whatever place
you listen to your music it should be
available there all the songs are also
available individually in video form on
my other channel which goes under my own
name called philippe hall
so you should definitely go subscribe to
that channel if you're interested in
more stuff like that and generally a lot
of content related to music which is one
of my other main
passions and activities so i hope you'll
enjoy the music and i look forward to
bringing you new videos about all the
topics related to religion history
philosophy and all the things we do here
in future videos and there are some
really exciting new ones coming out very
soon so stay tuned for that and i'll see
you then
you